while Ukraine says rescue operations are
being affected by constant Russian
shelling the Kremlin says emergency work
is deployed to that flood zone in
russian-hulled territory have come under
Ukrainian artillery fire the
russian-appointed governor for her son
says shelling hit an evacuation point
for residents of the town of hola
pristan killing two people well let's
speak to journalists Julia chapovalova
in Moscow Yulia we're hearing there's
been ongoing attacks but rescue workers
are still in the area right
well yes they are but to be precise uh
the the latest what we have here that
the Armed Forces of Ukraine uh fired at
the evacuation point for civilians in a
Goliath Princeton two people died
including a 33 year old pregnant woman
bear two more people were injured and
they are right now being taken to
hospital and according to acting
Governor over here Sona region of
Vladimir salder pristine is one of the
most affected areas Downstream of the
Nipper River all the water was rushing
there but Kremlin spokesperson actually
Dmitry peskov he praised the work of a
Russian emergency services and emergency
workers there saying that they're doing
great job and they continue rescuing
people under the constant shelling from
the Ukrainian side that was uh basically
a Kremlin spokesperson had to say and
according to Russian appointed mayor of
Novak five people have died due to the
tragedy to the to the situation at the
dam and 41 have been taken to hospital
in the russian-controlled Left Bank of
the Nipper River and earlier acting
governor of the Herson region again
Vladimir salder said that the shelling
from the Ukrainian side hampers the
rescue operation there but the emergency
operation is underway and drinking water
as well as food and power generators are
being supplied there more than 4 000
people have already been evacuated and
over 14 000 houses have been flooded and
the speed of the current orbit nipple
River has increased tenfold so it makes
the evacuation process really hard from
the flooded areas that does sound very
difficult so evacuations are ongoing as
we speak how much longer do we think
that'll take
so by the way I just forgot to mention
that the technical services at the
zaparesia nuclear power plant they
report that there is enough water in the
reservoirs for cooling down the reactors
meaning that there is no immediate
threat for that station so according to
reports from 22 000 to 42 000 people do
need help as all of them are struggling
in the affected areas right now but also
thousands of households agricultural
lands and numerous livestock have been
severely damaged there and even the the
authorities report about the evacuation
process and other Emergency Operations
there in the area locals say that
basically they have to cope
with their own basically the scale of
the disaster is enormous and help can't
reach all of those in need therefore
ordinary people have to bear the brunt
of the tragedy right now
journalist Julia chapovalova there for
us with the view from Moscow thank you
Julia